[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
moi si j'avais 53 minutes à dépenser je
marcherai tout doucement vers une
fontaine cette pensée est celle du petit
prince de saint-exupéry
il se trouve que moi aujourd'hui ici
avec vous j'ai quelques précieuses
minutes à partager accepteriez vous que
l'on profite de ce moment ensemble
pourrait tirer au maximum chaque seconde
chaque minute qui nous sont confiés
accepteriez vous que l'on prenne
ensemble le temps de découvrir d'entrée
au coeur d'une partition musicale comme
nous pouvons le faire nous musiciens
lors d'une répétition
accepteriez-vous qu'ensemble nous
marchions tout doucement vers une
société exemplaire
imaginé par un de nos plus grands
compositeurs romantiques français hector
berlioz génial orchestrateur illustre
chef d'orchestre remarquable écrivain
féru d'innovation technique et musicale
hector-berlioz imagine en 1844 ce que
serait pour lui la société idéale et
invente le fonya ou la ville musicale
il s'agit écrit-il d'une nouvelle de
l'avenir la scène se passera en 2344
euphonia une ville musicale ou
compositeur instrumentistes chanteurs
facteurs d'instruments musicologue se
côtoient et vivent ensemble dans le seul
but de partager comprendre et servir au
mieux la musique ville futuriste régie à
la fois par le progrès techniques et le
langage musical le fonio et bâti un peu
comme un orchestre avec un quartier une
rue pour chaque famille de musiciens
vous trouverez par exemple
l'arrondissement des percussionnistes
si vous suivez le boulevard des cuivres
1 vous arriverez dans le quartier des
cordes
qui entoure le magnifique jardin
botanique des bois
mesdames messieurs orchestre symphonique
les clés de fonua aujourd'hui lisieux
fonya et moi-même aimerions vous parler
d'un autre grand compositeur français
maurice ravel mais en 1875 à l'apogée de
la grande ère des chemins de fer et à
l'aube de celle de l'aviation fils
d'ingénieur passionné lui aussi par la
mécanique des machines et les progrès
techniques de son époque
maurice ravel l'horloger suisse comme le
surnommaient igor stravinsky est
aujourd'hui pour nous un modèle capable
de quitter la réalité de son époque de
découverte et de progrès pour nous
conter en musique
des victoires qui ont traversé les
siècles n'est ce pas une forme de
courage que d'oser prendre le temps de
s'arrêter pour créer partager contempler
s'émouvoir pensée est particulièrement
aujourd'hui dans une société où nous
cherchons est toujours plus efficace
plus rentables rapide à une époque
marquée par la révolution numérique et
la rapidité des échanges
alors soyons courageux et arrêtons nous
quelques instants afin d'écouter ravel
nous raconter les entretiens de la belle
et la bête
extrait des contes de ma mère l'oie mise
en musique entre 1908 et 1911
[Musique]
m
le premier ressenti est tout à fait
agréable charmant une musique paisible
au mouvement calme et serein vous avez
peut-être perçu le mouvement rythmique à
trois temps de la noble valls
[Musique]
vous avez sûrement reconnu instruments
mis en exergue dans le premier extrait
musical l'instrument féminin par
excellence depuis l'époque romantique la
clarinette douce tendre et sensuel
[Musique]
vous venez de faire connaissance avec la
belle sans le secours de la parole ravel
choisi dans un premier temps de nous
présenter ces deux personnages
principaux
il nous reste donc à découvrir la bête
pas de panique allons-y prudemment en
écoutant tout d'abord son accompagnement
s'il celui de la belle et douce
séduisant charmant celui de la bête
paraît beaucoup plus âpre froid dure
accentuée écoutez cet extrait est prêté
une oreille attentive au violoncelle et
contrebasse que vous entendrez trembler
d'effroi
tout comme la belle lors de leur
première entrevue
[Musique]
à
une question se pose pour ravel si la
clarinette assure représenter
magnifiquement la féminité la douceur la
fraîcheur de la belle quel instrument
pourrait symboliser la laideur la
douleur la solitude
l'enfermement de la bête on imagine
plutôt un instrument aux couleurs
sombres
pourquoi pas un instrument de la famille
des cuivres le corps par exemple dans
son registre grave
voici le thème de la bête au corps
[Musique]
c'est pas mal peut-être un peu trop rond
trop dit ou pas assez austère essayons
le violoncelle
[Musique]
trop chaleureux trop expressif trop
proche de la voix humaine
rappelez vous que la bête dans le compte
de madame leprince de beaumont est privé
de beauté mais aussi d'esprit sans
vouloir vexer nos contrebassiste
essayons cet instrument le plus grave de
la famille des cordes
[Musique]
ça pourrait marcher
mais est ce assez dense assez sombre
ravel va choisir le plus grave des
instruments de la famille des bois le
contrebasson rocailleux abrupte
maladroit inquiétant
[Musique]
le thème la mélodie vous l'avez entendu
dessine une ligne descendante et se
termine par une chute dans le grave un
affaissement qui symbolise la souffrance
le désespoir de la bête dans sa prison
dorée deux thèmes donc très différent
que ravel dans son introduction va
séparer par un silence musical qui
marque une rupture une fracture entre
deux mondes
à première vue terriblement
dissemblables un silence tendu qui crée
la tente les mois l'effroi vous pourrez
le vivre tout à l'heure comme vous le
savez nos deux personnages vont finir
par faire plus ample connaissance
la belle va apprendre à découvrir peu à
peu la bête est apposé sur elle un autre
regard
pour symboliser ce rapprochement ravel
va confronter les deux protagonistes les
deux thèmes en les faisant entendre
simultanément et si vous êtes attentifs
vous pourrez percevoir tout à l'heure
que le thème de la bête va se bonifier
au contact de la belle et quitter
progressivement le grave de l'instrument
pour monter dans un registre plus aiguë
des ténèbres vers la lumière est en
effet vous connaissez l'histoire la bête
va peu à peu prendre confiance et et
poser la question fatidique label voulez
vous être ma femme non la bête
et là c'est le drame
écoutez le cri la douleur du monstre
[Musique]
après quelques péripéties que ravel ne
nous compte pas en détail la belle
partie retrouvé son père malade va
revenir au château mais avec quelques
jours de retard retard fatale pour la
bête qu'elle retrouve à son arrivée
allongé dans le jardin se mourant de
chagrin je meurs content puisque j'ai le
plaisir de vous revoir encore une fois
non ma chère bête vous ne m'aurez pas
vous vivrez pour devenir mon époux
[Musique]
le geste magique de ravel un glisse cndd
au dollar alors la bête avait disparu et
elle ne vit plus à ses pieds qu'un
prince plus beau que l'amour qui l'a
remercié d'avoir fini son enchantement
tout cela est bien beau mais comment
musicalement
après ce coup de baguette magique
transformer la bête en prince charmant
après le glisse ndo de harpe que ravel
en bon scénographe fait encore une fois
précédée d'un temps de silence le thème
de la bête va apparaître non plus aux
contrebas son instrument le plus grave
de la famille des bois mais au violon
solo instrument le plus aigu de la
famille des cordes et ce en harmoniques
ce sont les sons les plus aigus les plus
éthérée les plus magiques qu'il soit
possible d'obtenir chez v cordes
contrebasson et violon deux instruments
aux antipodes de deux familles très
différentes
tout comme le prince et la bête mais si
l'apparence change radicalement
l'âme de la bête le thème musical reste
très reconnaissable
la musique va s'apaiser
le violoncelle solo va prendre le relais
du violon comme si l'envoûtement avait
complètement disparu et le prince repris
tous ses esprits et sa véritable nature
ravel vous l'entendrez termine sa pièce
dans une atmosphère de mystère de rêve
et de quiétude
je vous propose de prendre le temps
d'écouter dans son intégralité cet
extrême des contes de ma mère l'oie de
goûter les couleurs orchestrales de
suivre la belle de découvrir la bête et
de vous laisser toucher par cette
histoire musicale sans paroles
[Musique]
où
oui
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
à
oh
où
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous venons de partager un moment bien
particulier en prenant le temps d'entrer
dans la magie de la composition et de
l'orchestration de la pièce de ravel en
prenant le temps d'apprivoiser une bête
patibulaire que nous avons vu entendu
évoluer
c'est finalement peut-être elle qui nous
a procuré le plus d'émotions d'empathie
nous avons senti compris que la musique
ne se dévoilent qu'en prenant le temps
de l'écouter 2030
nous avons dix ans 3650 jour 87 mille
six cents heures 5 millions deux cent
cinquante six mille minutes
je vous épargne les seconds imaginez le
nombre d'oeuvres que nous pourrons
découvrir redécouvrir apprécié partager
le nombre de personnes que nous pourrons
rencontrer écouter aider le nombre
d'amis que l'on pourra prendre le temps
d'aimer le nombre de conférences ted que
l'on pourra savourer le nombre d'arbres
que l'on verra pousser d'enfants grandir
d'émotion ressentir en attendant
permettez moi de conclure en formulant
trois souhaits je souhaite que vous
puissiez un jour prendre le temps de
réitérer cette expérience d'entrée au
coeur d'un chef-d'oeuvre quel qu'il soit
je souhaite que vous ayez envie de
partager les émotions vous avez pu
ressentir au contact de cette musique et
enfin je souhaite
oui je souhaite que vous éprouviez
l'envi certes étonnante étrange
fantasque d'apprendre à jouer du
contrebasson
et alors nous aurons la preuve que nous
sommes encore les maîtres de notre
existence et non des pantins soumis à
des forces mécaniques incontrôlée et
qu'aujourd'hui ensemble véritablement
nous n'avons pas perdu notre temps
merci
[Applaudissements]